go with the Carol I think we've played
several times myself in windmill where I
played the Sicilian so let's go with
this instead and I'm really already
feeling comfortable right now feeling
comfortable because I don't know that
this night really is well placed this
pond can't move he's not able to move
that ought to worry about the queen bee
three or queen a5 a4 type of stuff
putting pressure on this pond that could
sometimes be a knee-jerk reaction when
your opponent develops their Queen
Bishop for you to bring out your queen
and then attack that week on I'm b7
which would then be unprotected let's go
rook here it's not an inconvenience
there's there was just the potential for
night c7 there but rook c8 that's
something I would have done anyhow
that's why I use the word convenient
there rook c8 it's half open file and I
just happened to be defending the threat
so he eventually gets kicked away with a
six if he if he turns out to bother me
and to be honest he's just not bothering
me but should I still kick him away
I'd like to trade lightscribe bishops
and get my night right here I think be
very uncomfortable to get a night on see
form you putting pressure on the
queenside ponds my other candidate was
our Bishop e7 I have a six Bishop e7 and
night here maybe this move preparing a
six and then when the night goes back I
can mess up the structure there
hmm I'm gonna opt for just more
development though maybe that's good
maybe this move was good too i like that
the night move but anyhow maybe I should
kick the way no no no not gonna kick the
night away I did think about it for a
second there just so white doesn't get
in let's say c4 but i think that fails
tactically i could take and then take on
this square because my rook is would be
hitting that Bishop unprotected peace
would come about on c4 about a 6 with
b-52 follow or just night here right now
right here still these are still
candidate moves 90 for a 6 with b-52
fall or night a 5 no drops the pond so
not this this before night here if
anything but a 6b five might be an idea
nighy for I think Bishop here could be
annoying let me go with this get that
night out of there he has one move and
before I do move like night here i'm
going to do b5 just so i don't have to
deal with a night getting to a 4 and
then see for one day whoa what's going
on here two pawns for the minor piece is
this enough clean here right away
pressure on the bishop and pon pon pon
king indirectly very indirectly but this
is the main thing development pressure
on the bishop and
just queen we capture or rook or take
this night first before pivots on this
square I think I like doing this just so
i have to deal with a g4 move than the
night getting to this square if the
Queen recapture is yeah this is working
out because now there's two ponds that
are hit and both can't be defended so
this is soon to turn into just me being
up a minor piece for a pond I don't know
that that was a good choice I'm not well
i'm also on this guy as well but if i
could get the beep on and a good label
something that i've referenced earlier
are in previous streams the term heart
this pond right here of this structure
this is the heart of the structure get
rid of him and then these guys become
very very weak I could take that right
away but i'm not going to there's no
need to it's hit once defended zero but
now it's hit twice defended zero it's
not going anywhere there's no rush with
taking it when i take that pond i want
to be in a spot maybe where I'm just
doing what where I'm controlling the C
file so I'm not going to take just yet I
want to maybe take this pond with tempo
so if the rook if the Queen plays here
then I could take the pawn and hit the
Queen
I do this pawn push I could take its of
some concern to me actually yeah there's
probably something better here yeah yeah
okay let's go with this and throw my
knight in there 94 94 I need a flight
square 2 i'm not liking my technique
here I maybe should have just stopped
getting fancy here with these in between
moves it should just take in right away
maybe it's better to have that Queen
right here because I could have been
taking this as follow-up now i can if i
take here i work myself into a pin of
Bishop back there's even pawn push which
is a little bit annoying let's go with
this I'm on this pond um pond here I go
Queen here that I could hang out on that
square for a little bit let's do that
right now and I don't know if I want to
take this it might even be some line
where the Queen takes the rook whoa that
might not be too far away either ok ok
ok ok ok ok let's do this let's get out
of that nonsense on push rook here and
then go after this guy he is the number
one guy i also have a threat of night
here
mmm Queen trade
Brook here Queen takes Queen let's not
do that ma'am there had to have been
something better
I'm going to take and then do this this
is very scary the pawn is pinned I'll do
this move to hit the bishop and create a
flight square I don't want to do
something calm let me do this right now
Pass palm this is a this is very scary
actually I think I just want to take
this pond next just saw these guys don't
get past yeah I'm going to take this
right now it's just too scary this is
this was really bad technique was this
bad technique bad bad bad bad bad watch
out for the sneakiness mate was being
threatened right there now actually the
tables are turned because I could hang
on to this pond so I think just taking
that right away would have been better
now this pond runs for I believe
touchdown touchdown coming up Knight d2
with check and then here the Rick needs
to go wait to check just play here and
King position ok night where do you want
to live where do you want to live night
go quick go quick grab a bishop cut the
king of get this pawn no stalemates
don't allow a stalemate whatever you do
this is the palm that runs no stalemates
don't allow it that's not Stanley ok
ah man I had a fantastic advantage and
you just saw it evaporate because of
poor technique has that ever happened to
you at the end of the day so I won the
game but things aren't going to always
end so pretty like that where you know
like I definitely messed up that
technique really really bad right there
so i'll have something to suggest for
myself for sure okay let's let's flip
this and look from White's perspective
I'm not really a fan of the exchange
carol con with the night being on c3 so
let that be the first thing I point out
I think it's better in this position to
play either d4 still a step in the
direction of the main line caro-kann or
Knight to f3 not really so sure of pond
takes okay so and I think because of
because of this decision to be taking
like this right here in response to d5
instead of going night here or d4 I
think it's difficult to come up with a
constructive plan so that's my first
point and now I guess well it's a white
felt compelled to going for some
imbalance right here but my next
suggestion is going to be for myself
namely right here I think it was okay
that I did the in-between move to take
out the night but right here right now I
should just quit and fancy and just grab
the silly pun I'm actually when I throw
in this in-between move of rooks III I
kick this Queen away to a defensive
square for this pond I should take c2
right away take on c2 right now silly
and then grab this pond next so I think
that would be in
provement for me I do have to be a bit
cautious these ponds gets pretty
annoying even right now take on c2 I
should have been going with that anyhow
and if I did this maybe I could get away
with it it's certainly pretty
uncomfortable though because of a pond
push and he's not too far away I do not
yet have a flight square that's another
thing that I have to be concerned with
and also the pressure than this rook I
can't really rely eventually this pond
once placed on a seven makes this rook
overloaded it's having to watch over
both the a8 square in the C 2 square and
that's not a good position to really
ever be in so that's that's a problem I
end up just taking this pond right here
and then just to be before it comes to a
connected past pond that's going to be
brutal that's why I felt the need to do
that in last point just go right in for
grabbing this pond I have a counter a
good counter attack I don't have to be
strictly defensive play f6 stop the mate
threat and then I could get behind the
pond so right here I don't know who
stands better maybe maybe I still do
just ever so slightly because of the
pawn structure and if I could get my
night here it's probably good but
certainly a lot more difficult to win
that one if I don't have this seat pan
around